hey this is presh tollwacker triangle
ABC is inscribed in a circle with a b
equal to AC equal to 12.
construct chord A D that intersects the
chord BC at Point e
suppose a e is equal to eight
the question is then what is the length
of the chord A D
the multiple choice options are 16 18 20
and there's not enough information to
solve the problem
I thank Kevin for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to solve this problem construct the
chord DC
now triangle ABC is an isosceles
triangle with a b equal to AC
therefore the angles ABC and ACB are
equal to each other and let their
measure be equal to Theta
now angle ABC is an inscribed angle of
the circle and it subtends the chord AC
but we also have angle ADC is another
inscribed angle of the circle and it
subtends the same Arc AC
therefore the inscribed angle ADC also
has measure equal to the angle ABC so
it's also equal to Theta
now we will show that triangles ADC and
a c e are similar
they have two equal angles of theta and
then DAC is equal to EAC
to see this more clearly here's triangle
ADC and here's triangle Ace
to see how they're similar we will scale
down this triangle then we will rotate
it and finally we will flip it
here's another illustration of how the
two triangles are similar
clearly they have two angles that are
equal to Theta and then the angles a are
equal to each other so we have mirror
images that are scaled from each other
therefore we have a d over AC in the
green triangle is equal to AC over AE in
the blue triangle
but we know that AC is equal to 12 and a
e is equal to eight so we can solve for
a d
a d is then equal to 12 squared divided
by 8 which is equal to 18.
thus the correct answer is B
now there's another interesting footnote
to this problem
while we can solve for the length of the
chord ad we cannot solve for the radius
of the circle
so it's actually interesting that the
length a d is the same and all of these
circles even though the radius of these
circles are different
amazing
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of buying your decisions where
we solve The World's problems one video
at a time
[Music]